our life did change but it didn't happen
instantly but that was just like an a
small example of how
not crazy we were but just like how much
we believed in just manifestation and
just speaking things in life at that
time 2008 like what the [__] are we
thinking well I'm 18 17. that's when I
had my first kid too so just like really
yeah life was just changing like we were
growing up like
I went through the exact same thing and
um I guess the whole Born Again thing
it's just like seeing life
um with no Veil
yeah just like seeing life for what it
is not expecting [__]
um not putting too much judgment out
there
um understanding you know you're just a
small part of this puzzle this energy
this field that you know everything
borrows from each other and we're just
regenerating
all that kind of [__] um so that's kind
of where the born-again thing comes from
like uh all right I see life for what it
really is now let's [__] go now it's
time to start the game of life and
that's when I got this tattoo I was like